This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《硬着头皮学》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在别处根本无法坦诚开展的真诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执业专业人士交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.
有多少男人穿着西装或铠甲？它向世界释放出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这么做。在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《硬着头皮学》。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这桩怀孕事件似乎是一场骗局。你曾把这个特定的测试篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
这需要大批网络侦探出动，才能揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷情网》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern. and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier,
随着剧集的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《深陷情网》播客。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。和担忧。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。《2%》。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟是同一个惯犯时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。收听《女朋友们》。
Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回望过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived. it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
在每一集中，我们都会精选年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，理清我们是如何熬过那段时光的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down and discuss the psychology of our 20s. Okay, so this is not our usual episode.
在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回望过去》。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你们身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴能迎来你们的回归，继续收听新一期的节目。当然，我们在这里将剖析和探讨我们二十几岁的心理学。好吧，所以这不是我们寻常的一集。
I think typically with the topics I choose to discuss, I want to make sure that most people can relate to them, right? I feel like there are some very universal experiences, not just of our 20s, but of being human, that I would say around like 80 to 90% of us can say, yeah, I totally get that. I've been there. I've experienced that I can see myself reflected in that topic. This one is for a unique subset of my listeners who can relate to a fear of flying. A fear of flying. That is what we
我想通常对于我选择讨论的话题，我都希望确保大多数人能够感同身受，对吧？我觉得有一些非常普遍的经历，不仅仅是在我们二十多岁的时候，而是作为人类的经历，我可以说大约80%到90%的我们都会说：是的，我完全理解。我经历过。我经历过这些，我能在那个话题中看到自己的影子。这一期是专门为我的一小部分听友准备的，他们能够体会到对飞行的恐惧。对飞行的恐惧。这就是我们
are going to talk about today. I have spoken about this on and off in certain episodes about how I was so terrified of flying that I didn't fly for like a very long time. And I would even do like, you know, 14, 15, 16 hour road trips in order to avoid a two-hour plane ride. But a listener actually DMed me the other day and she was asking me for this specific episode where I talked about it and I couldn't remember. So I thought, you know, I've spoken about it maybe for a couple of minutes here and there, but this deserves a full spot on the feed for people to come back to and to listen to if this is something that they fear and that they experience.
今天要讨论的话题。我在某些剧集中断断续续地谈到过这一点，关于我曾对飞行感到多么恐惧，以至于有很长一段时间我都不坐飞机。为了避开两小时的航程，我甚至会进行14、15、16小时的公路旅行。但前几天一位听友确实给我发了私信，她向我询问我谈到这一话题的具体是哪一集，而我记不清了。所以我想，你知道的，我可能在这里或那里谈过几分钟，但这值得在节目列表中占有一个完整的特辑，供大家回看和收听，如果这也是他们所恐惧和经历的事情的话。
So, yes, we are going to talk about a fear of flying, how it manifests, what it looks like, and of course, how to overcome it. I remember when I was really struggling with this maybe two years ago was when I really started to be committed to overcoming this fear. I was going through and like searching for answers everywhere. And I remember looking it up on TikTok, like what are the best tips for a fear of flying? And there were some great tips, but a lot of what I received was like informative videos about like plane safety and like interviews with pilots. And I really needed something else.
所以，是的，我们要谈谈对飞行的恐惧，它是如何表现的，看起来是什么样的，当然，还有如何克服它。我记得大约两年前我真的在为此苦苦挣扎时，正是我真正开始下定决心克服这种恐惧的时候。我当时在到处搜寻答案。我记得在TikTok上搜索过，比如对飞行的恐惧有哪些最佳建议？那里有一些很棒的建议，但我得到的很多都是关于飞机安全的信息性视频，以及对飞行员的采访。而我真正需要的是别的东西。
And I think I also realized that it was kind of a turning point for me where I was having all these huge opportunities to be able to go overseas to go to the US, go to Europe, fly everywhere and, you know, go to these events and travel. And I wasn't going to get that opportunity again. And if I let myself be held back by my fear of flying, I would really, really regret it. Now, I also have to say, when you live in Australia, like, those big, long international flights are definitely something you really have to, you know, it just adds a little bit more intensity to the fear. Like if I want to overcome my fear of flying and therefore give myself the opportunity to go to Europe or to experience like a beautiful Italian summer or to go to the US for work, that's like a 24, 30 hour commitment. And it was one of those flights that really like push me to finally get over this fear and find
我想我也意识到，那对我来说是一个转折点，当时我拥有所有这些绝佳的机会去海外、去美国、去欧洲、飞往各地，你知道的，去参加这些活动和旅行。而我不会再有这样的机会了。如果我让自己被对飞行的恐惧所阻碍，我会非常非常后悔。现在，我必须说，当你住在澳大利亚时，那些漫长的大型国际航班绝对是需要你真正去面对的，你知道的，这只会让这种恐惧更加强烈。比如我想克服对飞行的恐惧，从而给自己一个去欧洲的机会，或者去体验美妙的意大利之夏，或者为了工作去美国，那大概是一场长达24到30小时的旅程。正是其中一趟航班真正促使我最终克服了这种恐惧，并找到了
strategies that worked for me. Back in 23, I had this like really cool opportunity to fly in London to speak at like the podcast show and I was not going to give it up. So I want to talk about how I really got through it because now I'm not going to try and shoot my own horn here, but I'm a bit of an expert. Like I definitely still have my moments of fear and anxiety, but I really went about this in like a systematic way of like this is not going to control my life. And I will say I know it sounds like a very small privileged fear and in many ways it kind of is, but it can also hold you back from a lot of experiences that we want in our 20s, right? There is a lot of glamour and romanticism to solo traveling and to just traveling
对我管用的策略。早在23年，我有一个非常酷的机会，飞去伦敦在播客展上演讲，我是绝对不会放弃这个机会的。所以我想谈谈我是如何真正挺过来的，因为现在我不是想自吹自擂，但我算得上是个专家了。比如我确实仍会有感到恐惧和焦虑的时刻，但我确实以一种系统化的方式来处理这件事——这绝不能控制我的生活。而且我要说，我知道听起来这可能是一个很小、很具特权阶层色彩的恐惧，在很多方面它确实如此，但它也可能阻碍你获得我们在二十多岁时渴望的许多体验，对吧？独自旅行，以及泛泛的旅行，
in general and having backpacking experiences and summers abroad that if you really deeply fear flying, you can feel a lot of fomo around and feel like you are going to really miss out on, and therefore you're going to miss out on really getting everything that you can out of this decade. So hopefully by the end of this episode, you feel capable to have those experiences, even if getting on a plane and flying to whatever destination it is is part of it. Like, you feel capable of saying, yeah, I'm scared of this thing, but I'm going to do it anyway because this is what I want to do with my time and what I want to do in these younger years of my life. So yeah, we're going to talk about why we have a fear of flying, the different types of fears that
背包客经历以及在国外的夏天，都有着许多魅力和浪漫色彩，如果你极其恐惧飞行，你就会产生很多错失恐惧症（FOMO），觉得自己真的会错过很多，因此你将错过充分利用这个十年所能获得的一切。所以希望到这期节目结束时，你会有能力去拥有这些体验，哪怕登上一架飞机并飞往任何目的地也是其中的一部分。就像，你有能力说：是的，我害怕这东西，但我还是要去做，因为这是我想用我的时间去做的事，也是我想在人生年轻的几年里去做的事。所以，是的，我们要讨论为什么我们会对飞行产生恐惧，是什么不同种类的恐惧
create the broader fear and also why avoidance and ignoring the problem is only going to make it worst and the baby steps and the mental steps and the psychological steps that you can take and you can perform to be okay with getting on those long flights or even just getting on an hour long flight I really do believe that this is a fear that is easier to overcome than you would think so without further ado let's get into it That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
构成了更广泛的恐惧，以及为什么逃避和忽视问题只会让情况变得更糟，以及你可以采取和执行的那些微小步骤、心理步骤和精神步骤，从而能够坦然面对长途飞行，甚至仅仅是一小时的航程。我真的相信，这是一种比你想象中更容易克服的恐惧，废话不多说，让我们切入正题。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。《2%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回望过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一集中，我们都会精选年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何熬过那段时光的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的可卡因。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes.
为了说清楚，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为犯罪。可卡因。我随时准备聊聊可卡因的话题，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。现在我们桌上还摆着艾滋病。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《回望过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《硬着头皮学》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于赢与输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在人间时做个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《硬着头皮学》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标的真实对话。
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
打开免费的iHeartRadio应用，搜索《硬着头皮学》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己身处父子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了一场长达数年的诉讼战，旨在证明真相。你曾把这个特定的测试篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。大批网络侦探出动才破了案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Gregalespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷情网》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着剧集的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《深陷情网》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield）。在《女朋友们》的这个新季中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们约会的竟是同一个惯犯。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have a fear of flying, let me just tell you, you are not the only one, even if people don't really talk about it. There have been some recent estimates that about 40% of us have some fear of flying, and that has only increased since the pandemic. Obviously, because a lot of us weren't flying. A lot of us weren't having the exposure to an airplane or to air travel that would help beat a fear instead it was sustaining an anxiety through avoidance that you know bad things would happen when we get on a plane and we weren't having any of the experiences to prove that that would be the opposite
在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听。如果你有飞行恐惧症，请让我告诉你，你绝不是唯一的一个，尽管人们并不怎么谈论它。最近的一些估计表明，大约40%的人都有某种程度的飞行恐惧，而且自从大流行以来，这一比例只增不减。显然，因为我们很多人当时都不坐飞机。我们很多人都没有接触飞机或航空旅行的机会，而这种接触原本可以帮助战胜恐惧，相反，这种焦虑通过回避得以维持，即我们认为当我们登上一飞机就会发生坏事，而我们没有任何经历来证明情况恰好相反——
of the case like that wasn't going to happen i want to talk about where a fear of flying comes from um firstly by talking about my own experience so for me i felt like this just crept up on me when i was 18, 19, I solo traveled around Europe, like I made up with some friends, but my, to get to Europe from Australia, I did that all by myself. And I, you know, was not flying business class. I wasn't flying premium economy. I was flying like on China Airlines, China Southern Airlines, like not a great airline in like the back of economy. And I remember my flights being like $800 return and the food was awful. On one of my flights, like we didn't even have a TV screen and it was like 15 hours. Like the whole experience was like not a pleasant experience. And I was totally fine. Oh, and by the way,
事情并不会那样发生。我想谈谈飞行恐惧究竟从何而来，嗯，首先从我自己的经历说起。对我来说，我觉得这就像是在我18、19岁时悄悄找上门来的，当时我在欧洲独自旅行，虽然我和一些朋友汇合了，但要从澳大利亚去欧洲，我完全是独自一人完成的。而且我，你知道的，坐的不是商务舱。我坐的不是高级经济舱。我坐的是中国航空公司、中国南方航空公司这类航班，并不是什么很好的航空公司，坐在经济舱的最后面。我记得我的机票是800澳元往返，餐食糟糕透顶。在我的其中一个航班上，甚至连电视屏幕都没有，航程却长达15小时。整个体验绝对算不上愉快。但我完全没事。哦，顺便说一句，
like that ended up being like, I think a 30 hour flight because we had to do two flights with a huge layover. And I was completely alone that whole time. And like it wasn't the smoothest sailing. And I don't remember having any real fear. And the same on the way back as well. Like I actually I don't know if I've told this story before, but on my way back from Europe when I was 18, and like I did my first big solo trip, on my way back, I got stuck in Taiwan for the night, and I'd run out of money. Like, I didn't have any money on my travel account. I didn't have a SIM card for Taiwan.
那趟旅程最后好像变成了，我想大概30个小时的飞行，因为我们得转机两次，中间还有很长很长的中途停留。而且那整个过程我都完全是孤身一人。航程也并非一帆风顺。我不记得自己当时有过任何真正的恐惧。回程时也是一样。其实，我不知道自己以前有没有讲过这个故事，但在我18岁从欧洲回程时，那是我第一次大型独自旅行，在回程的路上，我在台湾滞留了一晚，而且我的钱花光了。比如，我的旅行账户里没有钱了。我在台湾也没有手机卡。
Like, I was completely and utterly kind of stuck. I wasn't sure if I was going to make the flight, and the whole experience was actually really stressful. and I still got on the plane and didn't feel any fear. In fact, I felt quite peaceful. And so I can reflect on those experiences and be like, oh, there was a time when, like, I really wasn't scared by this. And then COVID happened. The pandemic happened.
我整个人可以说是彻底且完全地滞留了。我不确定自己能否赶上航班，整个经历其实非常具有压力。但我还是上了飞机，心里没有感到任何恐惧。事实上，我觉得相当平静。所以每当回想起那些经历，我就会想：哦，曾经有一段时间，我真的没有被这东西吓到过。然后新冠疫情爆发了。大流行发生了。
I was meant to, I think, like a lot of us, I had these big travel plans because I was about to graduate university. Like, I had just graduated and I was like, great. 2020 is like my year for traveling and like I'm going to save up and I'm going to go to Russia like this was before the Ukraine-Russia war like look how much has changed like I was like I'm going to go to Russia and then I'm going to go to the US and maybe like a bit of Asia
我想和很多人一样，我当时有宏大的旅行计划，因为我正要大学毕业。我刚刚毕业，当时想：太棒了。2020年就是我的旅行之年，我要存钱去俄罗斯——这是在俄乌战争之前——看事情变化有多大——我当时想：我要去俄罗斯，然后我要去美国，可能再去亚洲的一小部分，
and just have a great time and I had no fear around getting on flight like it was not in my mind and then I didn't fly for two years no one really flew in Australia like if you're from Australia you know the lockdowns were like very, very intense. And then I had the opportunity to fly home, to see my parents in Melbourne. And oh my goodness, I remember going to book that flat and being like, oh my God, suddenly all of these fears are coming up for me.
过一段美好的时光，我对搭乘航班没有任何恐惧——这根本不在我的脑海里。然后我有两年时间没有坐飞机。在澳大利亚真的没有人坐飞机——如果你来自澳大利亚，就会知道那里的封锁非常非常严厉。后来我有机会飞回家，去墨尔本看望我的父母。哦天哪，我记得我去订那张机票时心想：天哪，突然之间，所有这些恐惧全都涌上心头。
Like I suddenly am picturing myself walking onto that plane. And the only sensation I can feel is like a deep pit. rock heaviness in my stomach. And I didn't book the flight. I drove down. And then when I had, when the time came to go back up, I drove back up again. Like, and it was like a 12, 13 hour drive. Like, it was ridiculous. And it was totally inefficient, totally, like, unsustainable, totally expensive as well. And that was my first, like, real moment of like, oh, wow, this like fear has suddenly emerged for me and it kept coming up all these opportunities to go and see family finally being able to see family like I would not catch a flight and then the one time that I did that I really
我突然想象着自己走上那架飞机。而我能感受到的唯一触觉，就是胃里有一个深深的、沉甸甸的、像石头一样沉重的坑。结果我没有订机票。我开车下去了。然后当时间到了要回去的时候，我又开车回去了。那是一场长达12、13小时的驾驶。太荒谬了。完全低效、完全不可持续，而且极其昂贵。那是我人生中第一次真正意识到：“哦，天哪，这种恐惧突然在我身上出现了，”并且它不断涌现，那些终于可以去探望家人的机会，我就是不肯坐飞机；而唯一一次我必须得坐飞机的时候，我却没上去——我当时差点就要登机了，然后心想：我要彻底抓狂了，我会，我记得当时有这样一种恐惧，觉得：我在飞机上一定会恐慌发作，我会试图逃下飞机。我会拉开应急出口，我会完全失控，无法控制自己。所以我不应该上这趟航班。我当时就是太害怕经历毫无准备的反应了。我太害怕自己的恐惧了。所以这就是我当时的状态，直到我意识到我必须改变某些事情。
had to I didn't get on it like I literally was about to board and I was like I'm going to fully freak out and I'm going to like I remember having this fear of like I am going to panic when I'm on this plane and I'm going to try and get out of the plane. I'm going to pull the emergency exits and I'm going to like fully freak out and I'm not going to be able to control myself. So I shouldn't get on this flight. Like I was just so terrified of having a reaction that I wasn't prepared for. And I was so terrified of my fear. So that is kind of where I was at when I realized I needed to change something.
因此对我来说，我认为 underlying（潜伏在）这背后的，一直是一种更普遍的幽闭恐惧症，以及对未知的更普遍的恐惧。但因为我小时候坐过很多飞机，因为我父母总是为了工作到处飞，后来又在我甚至还没到二十岁的时候就进行过长途飞行，所以我接触得足够多，以至于焦虑没有时间用幻想来滋养自己。所以，我的恐惧就是从那里来的。我想对于许多其他人来说，你的飞行恐惧可能源于一次负面经历——你刚刚经历了一次非常糟糕、极其恐怖的航班，这彻底塑造并主导了你对飞行的看法。我曾和某个人谈起过这件事，我的一个朋友，她对飞行有着极度深刻的恐惧，我希望她不介意我分享这个故事，不过我会对她匿名。她当时正从菲律宾飞回来，结果飞进了一场雷暴中，是一场闪电风暴。他们飞进了一场风暴，这是意料之外的，而且极其恐怖，飞机在剧烈摇晃，她以为自己要死了，听起来绝对糟糕透顶，就是从那时起，恐惧在她心里萌生了——那是一个触发事件，是她恐惧的催化剂。另一个非常常见的原因是，许多人在空难发生后报告称对飞行的恐惧有所上升。如果你还记得马来西亚航空370号航班（MH370），或者近年来坠毁的其他一连串航班，它们曾频繁出现在新闻中，每个人都在谈论，那是一场疯狂的悲剧，之所以会在人们心中留下烙印，是因为一种叫做“显著性效应”（salience effect）或“显著性偏误”（salience bias）的心理现象，即那些极其强烈、引人入胜、高度情绪化的新闻报道或正在发生的事情，会让人觉得它们实际上要常见得多，仅仅因为它们占据了如此多的头条新闻，占据了我们大量的思考空间——我们的大脑会想：啊，因为这件事更显眼，它肯定就更常见，尽管它只是成百上千次航班中的唯一一架。这是我们在“9·11”事件之后看到的一个重大现象。那其实是一个真正的转折点，让许多人从原本乐于登上一架飞机，转变为了许多人内心深处的抗拒与回避。甚至有些人直到现在——我曾读过一篇文章，说有些人报告称在“9·11”之前对飞行毫无恐惧，然而即便到了现在，距离当时已经过去24年了，他们依然因为记忆运作的方式、大脑如何影响我们的决策和行为以保护我们免受其恐惧、并在它确实发生时帮助我们生存——而事实是，像空难或航班上发生非常糟糕的事情这样的事，其实并没有那么频繁地发生。这其实与一个更广泛、更深层的理念相连：我们为什么会害怕飞行？
So for me, I think it was that I hadn't, I think underlying this there had always been a more. general like claustrophobia and a more general fear of the unknown but because i had flown so much as a kid because my parents were always traveling for work because then i'd done you know long a long haul flight when i was kind of not even in my 20s yet like i had been exposed enough that the anxiety didn't have time to feed itself with fantasy um so that's really where mine came from i think for a lot of others it could be your fear of flying comes from a negative experience so you've just had one really terrible, awful flight that has completely shaped and dominated how you think about flying. I was talking to someone about this, one of my friends, she has a really, she's a terrible fear of
你知道，许多人会说，我害怕坠机，或者我害怕颠簸，或者我害怕狭小的空间。所以在根本上，许多这类恐惧都可以归结为一种更深层、可以更简单归类的恐惧。其中最大的一项就是对未知的恐惧以及对失去控制的恐惧。所以很显然，当你登上飞机时，你就不再掌控一切了。如果真的发生了什么坏事，你其实什么也做不了。我知道这可能给了你一阵焦虑的冲击，但我们接下来会讨论如何克服它。但实际上，恐惧的本质就归结于这一点。如果你本身就是一个害怕不确定性、害怕无法控制周围环境、或是害怕未知的人，飞行可能就会成为一个真正的触发事件。这其实也与对坠机的恐惧息息相关，对吧？或者是对颠簸的恐惧，或是对航班上发生坏事的恐惧。你开始意识到，在这种局势和那一刻，你可能会相当无力。而那种无力感——那种感觉，可能是你潜在地感到不愿暴露于其中的。此外，还有更深层的恐惧或某种更深层的恐惧症——幽闭恐惧症。
flying and I hope she doesn't mind me sharing this story, but I'll keep it anonymous. She was flying back from the Philippines and they flew through like a thunderstorm, like a lightning storm. Like they flew through a storm and it was non-anticipated and it was terrifying and the plane was shaking and she thought she was going to die and it just sounded absolutely awful and it was like from then on now like the fear had emerged like that was a triggering event that was a catalyst for her fear another really big one is a lot of people experience or a lot of people report an uptick in their fear around flying after a crash so if you remember like mh 37 370 or a bunch of these other flights that have come down in recent memory that were everywhere
这也是对我影响很大的一种。我最大的问题是，我讨厌置身于封闭的空间里。我讨厌进电梯。我讨厌——在我对飞行的恐惧真正发作的那个时期，我甚至讨厌在悉尼坐地铁去上班。我甚至讨厌进隧道。所以这一切都归结于这种幽闭恐惧症。我特别记得，大约在这个时期，我会刻意避开在任何隧道里开车。
in the news everyone was talking about it it was a crazy tragedy that leaves an imprint because of something called the salience effect or a salience bias where really intense captivating highly emotional news stories or things going on feel like they're actually a lot more common just because they are dominating so much of the headlines and they're dominating so much of our thinking space like our brain is like, ah, because this is more apparent, it must be more common, even though it's only been one plane amongst hundreds and hundreds of thousands. This was a big thing that we saw following at 9-11. That was actually a real moment for people of, a real moment where a lot of people shifted from
每当我进入隧道时，我真的会感到恐慌在上升。我对隧道里出现交通堵塞感到格外害怕，因为我在想：天哪，我可不想被困在这个封闭空间的地下。那听起来简直就是我的终极噩梦。感觉一切都在朝我合拢。所以我还记得曾和我的一个朋友聊过，他因为工作需要经常到处旅行，我问他：“你怎么能忍受把自己锁在这个金属管里好几个小时？你进去，门关上，你就出不去了。
being totally happy to get on a plane to a real avoidance within a lot of people. And some people still, I was reading an article like there's people who reported having no fear about flying until 9-11 and even, what are we now, like 24 years on, like they still won't get on a plane because of how our memories work and how our brain influences our decision-making and our behavior to protect us from what it fears and to help us survive when really, you know, something like a plane crash or something really terrible happening on a flight doesn't actually happen all that often. This kind of links to a broader, deeper idea of why do we fear flying?
你做的任何事都无法让你离开。”而他当时对我说了一句非常美妙的话。他说：“是啊，但难道不是很美妙吗？因为当你悬浮在高空之中时，你实际上得到了一个远离现实的美妙假期。其实这相当特别。你可以彻底断开连接。你可以只管像这样，在这个完全属于你的时空中漂浮。”而我想：嗯，是的。
You know, a lot of people will say, I fear crashing or I fear turbulence or I fear the confined space. So at its root, a lot of these come down to a deeper, more simplistically labeled fear. The big one being the fear of the unknown and the fear of being out of control. So obviously when you get on a plane, you're not in control anymore. If something bad was to happen, there is nothing that you can do really. I know that probably gave you a jolt of anxiety, but we're going to discuss how to overcome that. But really, that's what the fear is coming down to. If you are someone who is already scared of uncertainty, who is already scared of,
我有点被他说服了。我还没完全接受。但我确实深刻理解他表达的意思。他还对我说，生活中会有很多这样的情况，你将不得不表现得有些坚忍。想想你生活中的许多其他事情，你身处一个无法改变的空间、活动、情况或情境中，你只能找到一种方法去接受它。因此，学习如何克服飞行恐惧，实际上它真正做到的，是教会你
not being able to control their environment or is scared of the unknown, flying can be a real triggering event. This also really relates to a fear of crashing, right? Or a fear of turbulence or a fear of something bad happening on the flight. You kind of realize that in that situation and in that moment, you might be quite powerless. And that powerlessness, like that feeling is one that you are not comfortable with potentially being exposed to. There's also the deeper fear or a deeper kind of phobia, claustrophobia.
许多关于如何应对不适感、焦虑感以及你总体上无法控制局势的深刻教训。它有助于教导你在生活的其他更广泛领域中如何做到这一点。但再次总结一下，这些就是我们害怕飞行的真正重大原因。我们害怕发生可怕的事件。也许我们害怕死亡，我们害怕受伤，我们害怕飞机坠毁，因此我们变得非常担心颠簸，我们开始对一些小细节感到忧心忡忡。然后，我们内心深处也存在着对未知的恐惧、对失控的恐惧，以及幽闭恐惧症——对封闭狭窄空间的恐惧。如果你对飞行感到恐惧，如果你不是一个熟悉这种感觉的人，
This was also one that was big for me. My big thing was I don't like being in enclosed spaces. I don't like getting in elevators. I don't like, at the time when my fear of flying was really happening, I didn't like even catching the train like into work in Sydney. I didn't even like going in tunnels. So it was all coming down to this claustrophobia. I remember specifically, like, I would avoid driving in any tunnels around this time.
这种感觉可能会伴随着大量对未来的焦虑（预期性焦虑）。我记得去年我坐飞机从巴厘岛去纽约，在那发生的整整两三天前，那几乎是我脑子里唯一能想到的事。我着魔了。我彻底着魔了。我在Google上搜索飞机到底是什么机型，我必须确切知道我的座位在哪里，我必须确切知道机上会供应什么食物，我们几点起飞，
And when I would go into a tunnel, I would really feel like the panic rising. And I was particularly scared of there being traffic in a tunnel because I was like, oh my God, I don't want to get stuck underground in this enclosed space. Like that just sounds like my worst nightmare. Like everything is closing in on me. And so I remember talking to my friend and being like, who travels so much for work and being like, how can you cope with being locked in this metal tube for hours? Like you get in, they closed the door, you're not coming out.
几点降落，所有可能出问题的可能性，巴拉巴拉巴拉，所有这些信息搜寻，其实都归结于预期性焦虑。就像，我在那个时间点其实并没有处于任何危险之中。我没有被触发。我并不处于我所恐惧的情境中，但我的大脑几乎就像是在说：“好吧，让我们通过现在几乎复制你最终会感到的焦虑来让你做好准备，这样你就能习惯了。”当然，这不管用。这根本不管用。你的大脑试图想出所有这些不同的方法来应对它认为困难的事情，但实际上，你能为你自己做的最大的一件事，就是直面恐惧，并看到你依然具备能力——我们最终会讲到这一点。与飞行恐惧相关的另一个重大感受是，当你登上飞机时。我会出汗。我会发抖。我会像，字面意义上整个人都在发抖，而且我会把脚上上下下地踩，像是在上下抖动着脚。一切都感觉非常、非常热。我觉得我需要逃跑。我简直觉得自己像只受惊的兔子。我发现其实在起飞前这种感觉是最糟的。但一旦我们在空中飞行了10到20分钟后，我就感到相当、相当平静了，因为我在想：“好吧，我现在已经身处其中了，我已经进来了。”那种“是的，其实我真的无能为力”的感觉占据了上风，而我想：“好吧，我不如干脆享受这段体验算了。”所以，这就是它的真实感受。它感觉像是一场恐慌发作。它感觉充满了焦虑的担忧。它感觉你被困住了。你试图战或逃（fight or flight），显然，试图逃跑或反抗这种让你感到受到威胁的事物，也就是坐飞机，但这一切都归结于——你的大脑中的恐惧中心和你的神经系统没有对你的环境做出正确的反应。因此，它在没有危险的地方看到了危险。是的，危险最终可能会出现，但你在那一刻其实并没有处于任何危险之中。你的大脑对环境和情境的解读是错误的。当我
Nothing you can do can allow you to exit. And he actually said something really beautiful to me. He was like, yeah, but isn't that really nice? because while you're suspended up in up in the air, like, you get this beautiful break from reality. Like, it's actually quite special. You get to completely disconnect. You get to just, like, float in this, like, space and time that is just, like, all for you. And I was like, hmm, yes.
开始意识到这一点时——即我对某事的焦虑想法并不会让任何事情变得更有可能或更不可能发生——这也对我是一种巨大的解脱。所以我们在这里做个简短的休息。当我回来时，我真正想深入探讨我关于如何克服飞行恐惧的建议。请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
Like, I'm slightly convinced by that. I'm not fully on board. But I do really see, like, where he was coming from. And he also said to me, he was, like, there are so many situations like that. you're going to be exposed to in life where you just have to be a bit stoic about it. Like think about so many other things in your life where you are in a space or an event or a situation or a context that you can't change and you just have to find a way to accept it. And so learning how to overcome a fear of flying, actually what it really does is teach you
我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。《2%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在
a lot of lessons about dealing with discomfort and anxiety and your inability to control a situation in general. It helps teach you how to do that in so many other broader areas of your life. But again, just to summarize, those are the real big reasons that we fear flying. We fear a terrible event occurring. Maybe we fear death, we fear injury, we fear the plane crashing, and therefore we become quite worried about turbulence, we become quite worried about small little things. And then we also have a deeper fear of the unknown, a fear of being out of control, and also claustrophobia, a fear of enclosed tight spaces. When you have a fear of flying, if you're not someone who's familiar with this,
《回望过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一集中，我们都会精选年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何熬过那段时光的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，
what this can feel like is a lot of anticipatory anxiety. So I remember last year I caught a flight from Bali to New York, and the whole two to three days before that happened, it was all I could think about. I was obsessed. I was obsessed. I was Googling what, kind of model the plane was going to be, I had to know exactly where my state was going to be, had to know exactly what food was going to be served on board, what time we were departing,
滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的可卡因。为了说清楚，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊可卡因的话题，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。
what time we were landing, all the possibilities of things that could go wrong and yada, yada, yada, like, it was all, this, like, information seeking was all coming back to anticipatory anxiety. Like, I wasn't actually in any danger at that point. I wasn't being triggered. I wasn't in the situation that I feared, but my brain was almost like, well, let's prepare you by almost copying the anxiety that you will eventually feel right now so you can get used to it. Of course, that didn't work. Like, it doesn't work. Your brain tries to come up with all these different ways to manage something that it sees
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。现在我们桌上还摆着艾滋病。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。
is difficult, but really, the biggest thing you can do for yourself is expose yourself to the fear and see that you are still capable, which we're going to get to eventually. The other big thing with the fear of flying that you're likely to feel is, like, when you get on the plane. I would sweat. I would shake. I would like like just literally my whole body would shake and I would be like pushing my foot up and down like bouncing my foot up and down. Everything felt very, very hot. I felt like I needed to run. I literally felt like a scared rabbit. And I found that actually that was the worst before takeoff. But once we were like 10, 20 minutes into the air, I felt quite, quite calm because I was like, okay, I'm in it now, I'm in it. Like the sense of like, yeah,
很难，但实际上，你能为自己做的最重要的事情就是让自己去面对恐惧，并发现你依然有能力应对，我们稍后会讲到这一点。你可能会感受到的另一种关于飞行恐惧的大事，就像你登机的时候。我会出汗。我会发抖。我的整个身体简直都在发抖，我的脚会上下蹬，就像脚在上下弹动一样。一切都觉得非常非常热。我觉得我需要逃跑。我真的觉得自己像一只受到惊吓的兔子。我发现其实在起飞前这是最糟糕的。但一旦我们在空中飞行了10到20分钟，我就会觉得相当平静，因为我想，好吧，我现在已经在里面了，我已经进去了。那种感觉就像，是的，
there's really nothing I can do took over. And I was like, well, I may as well just enjoy this experience. So that's really what it feels like. It feels like a panic attack. It feels like a lot of anxious worry. It feels like you are stuck. You are trying to fight or flight, obviously, trying to run away or fight back against this thing that feels like it's threatening you, i.e. being on an airplane, but it all comes back to like a real, like your, the fear center of your brain and your like nervous system is not properly responding to your circumstances. So it's seeing danger where danger is not. Yes, danger could eventually appear, but you're not actually in any danger in that moment. Your brain is reading the environment and reading the context wrong. And when I
真的没有什么是我能做的，这种情绪占据了上风。我想，好吧，那我不如好好享受这段经历。所以这真的是那种感觉。它感觉像是一次恐慌发作。它感觉像是大量的焦虑担忧。它感觉你被困住了。你试图战或逃，显然，试图逃跑或反抗这个感觉正在威胁你的东西，也就是身处飞机上，但这最终都归结为一种真实的、你的大脑的恐惧中心和你的神经系统对你的环境没有做出正确的反应。所以它在没有危险的地方看到了危险。是的，危险最终可能会出现，但你当时其实并没有处于任何危险之中。你的大脑对环境和语境的理解是错误的。而当我
began to realize that, that my anxious thoughts about something didn't make anything more or less likely to happen, that also was a great relief to me. So we're going to take a quick break here. And when I return, I want to really get into the tips that I have for overcoming my fear of flying. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the
开始意识到这一点，即我对某事的焦虑想法并不会让任何事情发生的可能性变得更高或更低时，这也是对我的一大解脱。所以我们在这里稍作休息。当我回来时，我想深入探讨我克服飞行恐惧的建议。请继续收听。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪现代世界中精神韧性、体能和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康行业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out.
我们真的曾相信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。就是数字的2%。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以去寻找答案。
on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill
在《Look Back at It》播客中。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，但只是想让你知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back At It。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师Kear Games。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐了
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person
以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。但我们仍在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得当一个好人很重要
while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way.
趁你还活在世上？你当好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹是因为想当一个好人。加入我Kear Gaines的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency. in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索Learn the Hardway并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧恩斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧恩斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻
as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
劳拉·欧恩斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这个新一季的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The biggest thing I can say to you if you have a fear of flying is that you need to find any possible way to stop avoiding the situation. to stop avoiding flying flights airports whatever it is and what you want to do is really approach that in slow manageable steps so i knew that when i was really getting ready to like beat this fear or at least
收听《The Girlfriends》。听我说，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你听播客的地方。如果你有恐飞症，我能对你说的最重要的一点就是，你需要找到任何可能的方法来停止逃避这种情境。停止逃避飞行、航班、机场等等，你真正想做的是以缓慢、可控的步伐来面对它。所以当我知道我真的准备好战胜这种恐惧，或者至少
find a way to handle it that i had this big thing coming up this big flight that i really wanted to do so i wanted to fly to london i wanted to make it there and i wanted to be able to get on that plane and you know, maybe not feel okay, but still be able to go through with it. So in the lead-up, like the six-month lead-up to this flight, I started doing small things to help myself. So I went to a flight simulator. I would watch videos on YouTube of people entering planes, like getting onto a plane, sitting down, showing their surroundings. Like, a lot of them were like reviews of certain seats on like different airlines like I'd watch like oh the emirates a380 like flight from doha to wherever like like what the seats would look like and what the meals were like to just really see then I also
找到一种应对它的方法时，我即将迎来一件大事，我非常想进行这次大飞行；所以我想飞往伦敦，我想去那里，我想能够登上那架飞机，你知道的，也许感觉并不太好，但仍然能够坚持下去。所以在前期准备阶段，也就是这次飞行的前六个月，我开始做一些小事来帮助自己。所以我去了一个飞行模拟器。我会在YouTube上观看人们登机的视频，比如上飞机、坐下、展示周围环境。其中很多都是关于不同航空公司特定座位的测评，比如我看过多哈到某地的阿联酋航空A380航班，看座位是什么样的，餐食是什么样的，为了真正看到然后我也
started saying yes to opportunities that would require me to do very short flights so one hour two hour flights around Australia and for the first couple of flights I took someone with me so I would literally be like okay does any of my friends need to fly to Melbourne this weekend. Let's see if we can get on the same plane. I paid for my dad to like fly on one of my flights with me to just help expose me to this fearful state. So the first flight I did was an hour. I think it was even less and I did it with my dad and it was hard. It was hard. But actually I realized by the end how proud I was, how much relief I felt getting off the plane and how I was like, wow, that was not as hard as I thought it was. And that's what the avoidance makes you.
开始对那些需要我进行非常短途飞行的机会说“好”，比如一小时、两小时的澳大利亚境内飞行。在前几次飞行中，我带了个人同行，所以我字面意义上会问：“我的朋友里有人这周末需要飞墨尔本吗？看看我们能不能坐同一架航班。”我出钱让我爸爸和我一起坐飞机，只是为了帮助我暴露在这种恐惧的状态中。所以我做的第一次飞行是一个小时。我想甚至更短，我是和我爸爸一起去的，这很难。真的很难。但实际上到最后我意识到我是多么骄傲，下飞机时我感到多么解脱，我当时想，哇，这并没有我想象的那么难。这就是逃避让你产生的
believe. It keeps you in this state where the biggest source of truth is your fear about a situation and your thoughts about a situation, often which are false. So the only truth you have to rely on is what your brain is coming up with. But when you actually expose yourself to the situation, a much different reality becomes apparent. I then did a two-hour flight with a friend, just me and her, and then a one-hour flight by myself. And that was really hard because we got stuck on the tarmac and that was something that I hadn't anticipated and it kind of threw me for a loop but what I did was I was just reminded myself of how it felt to have someone else there with me, how really like I was still able to do it by myself and I had a list of things that I knew would help
信念。它让你处于这样一种状态：真相的最大来源是你对一种情境的恐惧和你对一种情境的想法，而这些想法通常是错误的。所以你唯一能依靠的真相就是你的大脑所想出来的东西。但当你真正让自己暴露在这种情境中时，一个截然不同的现实就会显现出来。接着我和一个朋友进行了一次两小时的飞行，只有我和她，然后独自进行了一次一小时的飞行。那真的很难，因为我们在柏油跑道上被困住了，这是我没有预料到的，这让我有点不知所措。但我的做法是，我提醒自己和另一个人在一起是什么感觉，实际上我仍然能够独自做到这一点，而且我有一份清单，我知道这些东西能帮到
me out. So I still have this list in my phone and it's a number of strategies that I knew would calm my anxiety and break me out of a panic attack. So one of the them was to just do some guided meditation to do a breathwork exercise. I actually downloaded this app called the dare app, which I've spoken about before. And they do guided meditations for a fear of flying and guided meditations for panic attacks. And I would just sit and I would listen to that meditation and still I felt better. I also would just do jumping jacks at the back of the plane like in the little flight attendant area just until I felt better or squats, something that like make me feel like I was escaping or doing something about the anxiety within me.
我。所以我手机里仍然存着这份清单，里面有很多我知道能够平息我的焦虑并帮我摆脱恐慌发作的策略。其中之一就是做一些冥想引导，做一个呼吸练习。我其实下载了一个叫Dare的应用程序，我以前说过这个应用。它们提供针对恐慌发作和恐慌发作的引导冥想。我就会坐着听那个冥想到我感觉好点。我也会在飞机的后部，也就是乘务员的小区域里做开合跳，直到我感觉好点，或者做深蹲，做一些让我觉得我在逃离或者在处理内心焦虑的事情。
I put cold water on my wrists. I had something sour to buy into. I also would bring coloring in books. I just had a lot of, it almost felt like I was building a military, right? Like I was building my line of defenses against this anxiety. And I said, I'm only allowed to panic if I get through all these things and I don't feel better. Obviously, you know, maybe my anxiety would be able to do.
我在手腕上抹冷水。我吃点酸的东西来咬一咬。我还会带填色书。我有很多，感觉几乎像是在建立一支军队，对吧？就像我在建立对抗这种焦虑的防线。我说，只有在我尝试了所有这些事情而且感觉没有好转的情况下，我才被允许恐慌。显然，你知道，也许我的焦虑能够做到。
jump a couple of hurdles but I had a whole list of things that I could do so there was no way that it could get through all of them something was bound to work something was bound to make me feel better and I also just allowed myself to be okay with being scared I was like okay I'm just going to accept this feeling like I feel anxious but I'm going to look around at my environment is there anything to feel anxious about is there anything to feel scared about And what I would do is I would look to other people and I would mirror their response. So I'd look at the people in front of me. I'd look at all the heads of the people on the plane and I'd be like, okay, well, these people seem fine.
跨越几个障碍，但我有一整串我可以做的事情，所以它不可能穿透所有这些，总会有办法管用的，总会有些东西能让我感觉好点。我也允许自己接受害怕的状态，我当时想：好吧，我只是要接受这种感觉，我感到焦虑，但我环顾四周，我的环境有什么好焦虑的吗？有什么好害怕的吗？而我的做法是观察其他人并模仿他们的反应。所以我看我前面的人。我看飞机上所有人的头，然后我会想，好吧，这些人看起来没事。
These people aren't panicking. So obviously, like, if I can't trust myself and my own evaluation of this situation, I can trust theirs and they seem okay. I also reminded myself something that I knew very much to be true. It's the biology of us as humans, our psychology is that we cannot panic forever. So even if I was on the verge of a panic attack, I knew that eventually it would subside. So it was okay if I felt myself falling into the state. It wasn't going to last forever. It was eventually going to go away.
这些人没有恐慌。所以很显然，如果我不能相信自己对这种情况的评估，我可以相信他们的，他们看起来没事。我也提醒自己一件我深知是真实的事情。这是人类的生物学特性，我们的心理机制就是我们不可能永远恐慌。所以即使我处于恐慌发作的边缘，我也知道它最终会消退。所以我感觉自己陷入这种状态也没关系。它不会永远持续下去。它最终会消失的。
I know that my body could only sustain panic and that level of alertness and stress for so long. So I remind myself, it's just sensations. You know, it's just my body trying to. protect me, it doesn't change what is actually happening. I also want to say flight attendants, they know how to handle this. They see this all the time. And I've actually seen a flight attendant help someone who was panicking on a flight. I've seen random strangers help someone who was panicking on a flight. You've got to remember, most people are very, very kind and very, very good. if you were sitting next to someone on a plane who turned to you, turn to you and said,
我知道我的身体只能承受那么长时间的恐慌、那种警惕和压力水平。所以我提醒自己，这只是一些感觉。你知道的，这只是我的身体在试图保护我，它并没有改变实际发生的事情。我还想说，空乘人员知道如何处理这种情况。他们经常看到这种情况。我实际上见过空乘人员在航班上帮助一个恐慌的人。我见过素不相识的陌生人在航班上帮助一个恐慌的人。你必须记住，大多数人都是非常非常善良、非常好的人。如果你在飞机上坐在一个人旁边，他转向你，转向你并说：
I'm really, really scared. Would you dismiss them? No, you'd be like, I totally understand. Let me help you. So you've got to understand that most other strangers will also do that for you as well. Most people are genuinely very nice. And even if they aren't, the flight attendants have to be. Like, they're getting paid to be there. They aren't just decorative. Like, they have done a lot of training. And their training also involves how to hand. really heightened emotional states for people for whom this is a big fear. My other biggest, biggest tip, the thing that I still swear by to this day, and this is particularly the case with long haul flights, is to don't, like just don't let yourself be bored,
我真的、真的很害怕。你会打发他们走吗？不，你会说：我完全理解。让我来帮你。所以你必须明白，大多数其他陌生人也会为你这样做。大多数人骨子里都非常好。即使他们不是，空乘人员也必须是。因为，他们拿了工资在那里工作。他们不仅仅是摆设。而且他们接受过大量的培训。他们的培训还包括如何处理人们高度情绪化的状态，对于那些把这视为极大恐惧的人来说。我另一个最大、最大的建议，我至今仍深信不疑的建议，特别是在长途飞行中，就是不要——不要让自己感到无聊，
create itineraries for each flight. The same way that you might wake up and you might create a timed to-do list about your day, or like you would create an itinerary for like a holiday of like in the morning we do this in the afternoon we do this in the evening we do this like these are our activities for the day i would do the same for each of my flight and the day before i would make one of these itineraries so let me see if i can pull one up from my flight to london that i was talking about okay here it is i've managed to find it so we had two flights this was flight one i will also say that for my flight to london at the last minute I did ask my dad to come with me and I paid for his flight which is something I felt
为每一次飞行制定行程。就像你可能会醒来并为自己的一天制定一个限时待办事项清单，或者你会为假期制定一个行程，比如早上我们做什么，下午我们做什么，晚上我们做什么，这些是我们一天的活动，我也会为我的每一次飞行这样做，在前一天我会制定这样一个行程：让我看看我能不能找出我飞伦敦那次飞行的行程，我之前提到过的。好吧，在这里。我找到了。我们有两个航班，这是第一航班。我还要说的是，对于去伦敦的航班，我在最后一分钟确实要求我爸爸和我一起去，我支付了他的机票费用，我觉得
very lucky to be able to do I had all these points that I had been like saving up for literally like because I wasn't flying anywhere but before COVID I flew a lot and I'd like saved up all of these points for that trip to Europe I was meant to be doing never use them so I use those to get my dad a flight so that he could come with me because I was really really scared but this is what my itinerary looked like so hour one talked to my dad and get settled our two I had my routine, like my nighttime routine. So I got a face mask. I brushed my teeth.
自己非常幸运能够做到这一点。我积攒了所有这些积分， literalmente，因为我没有飞任何地方，但在疫情之前我飞了很多，我为那次要去欧洲的旅行攒了所有这些积分，结果从未使用过。所以我用这些积分为我爸爸买了一张机票，这样他就可以和我一起来，因为我真的、真的很害怕。但这就是我的行程表：第一小时，和爸爸聊天并安顿下来。第二小时，我有我的日常，也就是夜间护理日常。所以我用了面膜。我刷了牙。
I put on my noise canceling headphones. Hour two again, put on a movie. Hour three. Finish movie and do some knitting. Hour four. Have my first round of snacks. Eat meal. So like I was scheduling things to look forward to for each hour.
我戴上了降噪耳机。第二小时，再看一部电影。第三小时。看完电影，织一会儿毛衣。第四小时。吃第一轮零食。吃正餐。所以我把每个小时的事情都安排好，让我有所期待。
Hour five, start second movie. Get ready for sleep. Take a melatonin. Then it was like hour six, hour seven, hour eight. Sleep. but if not I had alternatives, which was to edit some of my podcast episodes or to do some coloring in. I even had other things to do as well. Like I had a little Lego set. So I had activities. Like I was prepared. Then our like 10, 11, 12. I had like instructions to make Instagram posts.
第五小时，开始看第二部电影。准备睡觉。吃一颗褪黑素。然后就是第六小时、第七小时、第八小时。睡觉。但如果没有，我还有别的选择，那就是剪辑一些我的播客节目，或者做一些填色。我甚至还有别的事情可做。比如我有一套小乐高。所以我有很多活动。我做好了准备。然后大约是第10、11、12小时。我有制作Instagram帖子的说明。
Like I had everything set up so that I had more things to do. Movie three. And then hour like 14 prepared to land. And then my second flight, this is what I said. I said, it was an eight hour flight. I said, this is just like a nine to five workday. Like, that is what this is. If I would easily sit in an office for eight hours in the same space that I would sit in a chair on a plane, like this is the same amount of time. So I had my hour one get settled, have some snacks, listen to a podcast, hour two, do another face mask. Hour three, I could either write some episodes or write my books. I was writing my book at the time. Or I could watch a movie. I was movie, movie, right, right.
就像我把一切都安排妥当，好让我有更多的事情可做。第三部电影。然后大约第14小时，准备降落。接下来是我的第二个航班，我是这么说的。我说，这是一次八小时的飞行。我说，这就像一个朝九晚五的工作日。这就是它的本质。如果我能轻松地在一个办公室里坐八个小时，和我在飞机椅子上坐着的空间一样，这就相当于相同的时间。所以我有了第一小时：安顿下来，吃点零食，听播客；第二小时：敷另一次面膜。第三小时：我可以写一些剧集或者写我的书。我当时正在写我的书。或者我可以看电影。看电影，看电影，写，写。
Hour seven, listen to a podcast, read hour eight, talk to dad, prepare to land. So like I had this itinerary for myself that would help me feel like my time was full. The day before my flight as well, the morning before I would go and get everything that I needed to buy slash needed to bring with me slash wanted to have. So this is what I had for like the list. I needed to buy sour candy, compression socks, a puzzle book. I also brought magazines and eye mask, toothbrush and toothpaste, portable charger, water bottle. I also bought my prescription, sour candy. I also had instructions for myself to download five movies.
第七小时：听播客，阅读；第八小时：和爸爸聊天，准备降落。所以我为自己制定了这个行程，这能帮我感觉时间很充实。在飞行的前一天，也就是出发前的早上，我会去买齐/带上我需要买的、需要带的、想要拥有的所有东西。所以我的清单上有这些东西：我需要买酸糖、压力袜、益智书。我还带了杂志、眼罩、牙刷和牙膏、便携充电器、水瓶。我还买了我处方的酸糖。我还有给自己的指令，要下载五部电影。
That seems a little bit excessive. Make sure that everything was charged, wear comfortable, but fashion will close, which will come into the next tip that I have. And then the morning of my flight, I went for a really big swim and a really big run. so that I was exhausted. Then I had an everything shower and had a really healthy breakfast. All of these things like putting myself in the best possible place to be prepared for this flight. And I had a daily reminder at the top of this list. So this is my list that I have on my phone called flight prep. I haven't updated it since the 3rd of December. But the reminder on the top of my phone said,
这似乎有点过头了。确保所有东西都充好电，穿着舒适但时尚的衣服，这就引出了我的下一个建议。然后在飞行的那天早上，我去进行了一次非常大强度的游泳和跑步，这样我就筋疲力尽了。然后我洗了个彻底澡，吃了顿非常健康的早餐。所有这些事情，比如让自己处于最佳状态，为这次飞行做好准备。我在这个清单的顶部放了一个每日提醒。这是我手机里一个叫做“飞行准备”的清单。自从12月3日以来我就没有更新过它。但手机顶部的提醒说：
you need to do hard things to grow, acknowledge the fear and run towards it anyway. And so I had this huge comprehensive list to come back to. And can I tell you something? Those itineraries, that whole plan, I didn't once have to use it. Not once. It was so important that it was there. But once I got onto the plane and I settled in and I maybe did the first hour or two of my routine, I realized that all of this preparation, really what it was doing was just making me feel more at ease with the possibility of discomfort.
你必须做困难的事情来成长，正视恐惧并迎难而上。所以我有一份庞大而全面的清单可以回头查看。我能告诉你们一件事吗？那些行程，整个计划，我一次都没有用过。一次都没有。它在那里非常重要。但一旦我上了飞机，安顿下来，可能完成了我的日常中的前一两个小时，我意识到所有这些准备工作，真正起到的作用只是让我对可能出现的不适感感到更加安心。
But after the first hour, I wasn't uncomfortable. I wasn't scared. I wasn't anxious. I was okay. So I was really able to relax into the situation. That is really what this preparation taught me is that you can do all that you want to do. But when you are in the situation, the chances are it's not going to be as bad or as hard as you've been. previously thought it was. Now, I want to bring us all back to that thing I said before that
但在第一个小时之后，我并不难受。我不害怕。我不焦虑。我很好。所以我真的能够在这个环境中放松下来。这正是这种准备工作教给我的：你可以做所有你想做的事。但当你身处其中时，情况很可能不会像你之前想象的那么糟糕或艰难。现在，我想把大家的注意力拉回我之前说的那句话上，
may have sounded strange. We're comfortable but fashionable clothes. This links to something that I still do to this day, which is that I romanticize the privilege and the act of flying by, and this is going to sound really silly, imagining that I'm someone really famous or really important. And the person that I tend to imagine is that I am Taylor Swift and that I am. Taylor Swift and that I am. getting on my flight and that this is just part of business and I romanticize this whole process of like having the opportunity to be a jet setter what that means like what that feels like and like would that person feel anxious would like Taylor Swift feel anxious about flying probably not like would Beyonce feel anxious about flying probably not like this is this is like what they do like
听起来可能很奇怪。穿着舒适但时尚的衣服。这与我至今仍在做的一件事有关，那就是我把飞行的特权和行为浪漫化了，说出来可能很傻，我假装自己是一个非常有名或非常重要的人。我倾向于想象自己是泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift），我是泰勒·斯威夫特，我是。泰勒·斯威夫特，我是。正在登机，这只是工作的一部分，我将整个过程浪漫化，比如有机会成为一名环球飞人意味着什么，那是什么感觉，那种人会感到焦虑吗？泰勒·斯威夫特会对飞行感到焦虑吗？大概不会。碧昂丝会对飞行感到焦虑吗？大概不会。这就是他们所做的事情——
this is what it means to be someone who is successful and I kind of like to pretend that I'm someone else in that moment. I am someone more capable. I am someone for whom this is really, really normal and it really, really works. Visualizing and romanticizing the process, visualizing getting off the plane as well, visualizing what it's going to feel like to literally put your feet on the tarmac or on like the, whatever it is, like the walkway, like visualizing that sensation, visualizing your first breath of fresh air when you get off the plane, also really, really profound. Like your mind has, like, has so many superpowers and hidden talents and hidden capabilities built into it to get you through hard situations. And its ability to reflect and remember and visualize and imagine future situations or past peaceful situations is something that you can use to really pull yourself into a calm.
这就是成为一个成功人士的意义所在，我有点喜欢在那一刻假装自己是别人。我是一个更有能力的人。我是一个对这种事情感到非常非常正常的人，而且这真的很有用。将这个过程可视化并浪漫化，把下飞机的过程也可视化，把双击踩在柏油跑道上或通道上——无论是什么——那种感觉可视化，把下飞机时呼吸的第一口新鲜空气可视化，这也非常非常深刻。你的大脑拥有如此多的超能力、隐藏的天赋和内置的隐藏功能，可以带你度过艰难的时刻。它反思、记忆、可视化以及想象未来情境或过去平静情境的能力，是你可以用来让自己真正平静下来的东西。
space when you are maybe panicking or you are maybe spiraling. I also mentioned having a go-to meditation that you know and you have proven to yourself can bring you out of a stressed state. Mine was the dare meditation. That's really useful. And finally, have a backup calming option. Now, I'm not going to tell you to go out and get a Valium prescription or to rely on prescription drugs or whatever it is or melatonin or something herbal or even like a glass of wine
当你可能感到恐慌或情绪失控时，你可以进入这样一个空间。我还提到了有一个你熟悉且已经证明能带你脱离压力状态的备用冥想。我用的是Dare冥想。这真的很有用。最后，准备一个备用的平静选项。现在，我不是在告诉你去开一剂安定处方，或者依赖处方药，或者褪黑素、草本制剂，甚至是一杯葡萄酒
but just knowing that you have it there without having to use it is incredibly helpful so i did have a valium prescription but let me just tell you i didn't touch it like i for a lot of my long haul flights now slash ever like i think i've only taken it once and it was because i was really like I was feeling quite ill and I was also really like not feeling well mentally. I was like hadn't slept for like a couple of days just because I'd been so run off my feet and jet lagged. That was the only time I used it. But I have taken so many international long haul flights where I have not needed it. But just the fact that I have it in my toiletries bag or that I know I can have a glass of red wine and feel better even if even though I don't drink on flights.
但只要知道它就在那里，而不必真正使用它，就已经具有不可思议的帮助了。所以我的确有安定处方，但老实说，我连碰都没碰——在我的很多长途飞行中，现在或曾经都是如此，我想我只吃过一次，那是因为我真的感觉很不舒服，而且精神状态也很糟糕。我有好几天没睡觉了，因为我太忙碌且有时差。那是唯一一次我使用它。但我进行过无数次国际长途飞行，根本不需要它。但仅仅是因为它在我的洗漱包里，或者我知道即使我不在飞机上喝酒，我也能喝一杯红酒然后感觉好点。
That has been so powerful. Again, it's just giving your. brain and giving yourself all of these hurdles that it has to jump over before you are going to let yourself panic. So having all of these different things that you can focus on, that you can zoom in on, that you can feel comforted by before you feel like you have to let your sensations take over. I want to also remind you of that reminder I had at the top of that list. In order to grow, you have to do hard things. So if you are someone who has avoided flying, who is scared of it, it feels really uncomfortable, it does get easier and you do see more of the
这就已经非常强大了。再次强调，这只是给你的大脑和你自己设定了所有这些障碍，在允许自己恐慌之前，你必须跨过这些障碍。所以在你觉得自己必须让那些感觉接管一切之前，你可以专注于所有这些不同的事情，你可以聚焦于它们，从中获得安慰。我还想提醒你我那份清单顶部的提醒。为了成长，你必须做困难的事。所以如果你是一个一直在逃避飞行、对它感到害怕、觉得很不舒服的人，它确实会变得更容易，而且你会看到更多回报。
rewards of putting yourself in a hard situation, an uncomfortable situation, something that you don't actually want to do, but which you are able to come out of and realize that you are so grateful to yourself for doing it. And it's actually not very common, I think, in our day and age that we do things that are very difficult and that we push ourselves really hard into a place of discomfort and even fear and are still able to come out the other side and see the rewards. Flying when you have a fear of flying is such a great opportunity to feel what it really means to, you know, feel deeply proud of yourself and deeply accomplished for doing the hard thing over the easy thing. So I'm wishing you so much luck. I know this is really, really hard, but I
让自己置身于艰难的情境、不舒服的情境中，做一些你其实不想做但最终能走出来并意识到自己为此深感感激的事情。而且我认为在我们的时代，做非常困难的事情，把自己狠狠地推向不适甚至恐惧的境地，却依然能够走到另一端并看到回报，其实并不常见。当你害怕飞行时，飞行正是去感受那种对自己的深深自豪感的绝佳机会，因为你知难而上，而不是选择了逃避。所以我祝你们好运。我知道这真的很难，但我也
also want you to know that as someone who used to be so afraid that she would get off flights, that she would drive freaking 13 hours to get places who, you know, avoided so many opportunities because of her fear. I have been able to get over it. Yes, like it's not completely gone, but in like two weeks I'm flying solo to the US for work and then flying back. And that's like a 15 hour flight and the level of anxiety I feel about it is nowhere near what I would have experienced two or three years ago and I feel completely fully capable of doing it and I believe that you can feel that way as well. So I'm sending you lots of love, peace, strength, calm and the opportunity to really push yourself and to learn and to see what you are capable of. Thank you so much for
想让你知道，作为一个曾经极度害怕坐飞机以至于会开车开足13小时去某个地方的人，一个因为恐惧而错失了无数机会的人。我已经克服了它。是的，它并没有完全消失，但再过两周我要独自飞往美国工作，然后飞回来。那是一次15小时的飞行，我对它感到的焦虑程度远不及两三年前的我，而且我完全觉得我有能力做到这一点，我相信你也能有这种感觉。所以我向你们发送许多爱、平静、力量、镇定，以及真正挑战自我、学习并发现自己潜能的机会。非常感谢大家
listening to this episode. If you are someone who also has a fear of flying and you have a tip or a suggestion or a piece of advice that you personally have used that I didn't mention, please drop it in the comments below. I would love to have the comment section on Spotify just be a huge page and peace and community notice board of advice and feedback and tips and tricks for all of us to learn from each other. I think that would be really, really useful. And again, send this to someone who you think might need.
收听本期节目。如果你也是一个有恐飞症的人，并且有我没有提到的你自己用过的小贴士、建议或心得，请在下方的评论区留言。我很希望Spotify的评论区能变成一个充满和平与社区意识的巨大留言板，供大家分享建议、反馈、技巧和窍门，互相学习。我认为那会非常非常有用。再次提醒，把这期节目分享给你认为可能需要的人。如果你有一个朋友也有这种经历，他是那40%的人群之一，或者你的父母或家庭成员因为我们谈到的一些原因一直在逃避或推迟飞行，也许这可以帮到他们。所以请随意分享。如果你还没有这样做，请务必关注《The Psychology of Your 20s》。给我们留下五星好评，并在Instagram上关注我们@That Psychology Podcast。如果你对本期节目有更多的想法、问题、疑问，或者想推荐其他主题，我非常喜欢听你们在各处与我交流。下次见之前，保重。善待他人，善待自己。祝你飞行愉快，旅途安全。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》
to hear it. If you have a friend who you know also experiences this, who was one of the 40% or a parent or a family member who has been avoiding or putting off flying for some of the very reasons we talked about, maybe this could help them. So feel free to share it. And if you haven't already, make sure that you are following along the psychology of your 20s. Leave us a five-star review and follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you have further thoughts, questions, queries about this episode, or you want to suggest another episode. I love hearing from you all over there. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle to yourself. Happy flying, safe travels. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the
我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在别处根本不敢进行的坦诚对话，而你是与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下一对双胞胎。
hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧恩斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·兰奇尼。我惊呆了。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧恩斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神韧性、体能和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你听播客的地方收听《2%》。即TWO.%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target.
他休想就这样逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。收听《The Girlfriends》。听我说，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你听播客的地方。在《Look Back At It》播客中。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the look back at it, podcast.
对1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并尝试与我们的朋友、同仁喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时期的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代一样。84年真是疯狂的一年。
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back At It。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是一个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。